おがーよーございまーす
朝6時半ぐらいデー
眠い重翁は何回か来たことあるんですけどもさっき止まった場所が可視化し民家って
言うんですがホテルとかじゃなくて
ウィンカーらしい人が住みが古民家をきれいにリノベーションというのかなう
人生がたと思った n メイションステップをリフォームてが綺麗にしてそこに人を
済ませるって言ってず進んだんですけども
全7巻と全く第1号だったらしくてめっちゃキレイな家ですごい住みやすかっ泳いで
沖縄に来ております
見てる通りなんですけどね
を
こんな犬見たことないぜ犬
犬
[音楽]
6年いるに参りますの島で惜しまず動いて御願いまで今日は完全にも沖縄端っこという
かちょっと外れの部分に来てるみたいなんですごい大自然が広がっておりますなぁ
それ相撲随一とですね海が見えてくるんでそこもに出してしようと思います
でああ
ん
[音楽]
白いナースながはい強気でちょっとあいにくの曇りなんですけどもなんか動画的には
曇りの方が顔が kumon ないからいいんですって
多分動画たらには一番いい天気だと思われます
沢山の忘れ物です
[音楽]
ああああああああ
[ __ ]
あーん
ろろー靴だとヨボいえっでもやばよい
ガチガチってをやってこい
これが入っていいんでしたーくん付ゲー
[音楽]
食べ閉じ込めて止めてくれぼすごいなんか本当にすごい
fon がヤバいよええ
蛇出てきたら5夫いやーもうマムシぐらいしか出てこない
始めてるってことでしょたとえ先に行きなさいはいかかりましたん
[音楽]
ってどんもうずっとずっと
もうまずでずっと続いてますよ
言いましょう
うわあああってキャッチじゃんこわー
えっ
閉所恐怖症なんすよねー
斬剣で負けたら意向を受け最初はなくなぜ1本入っ
くっそ
[音楽]
待って添えそんなに行ける
ああ
もうちょっとわかりやすい説明を求むむちゃくちゃ星がいますん
me
あっはぁ
あんちゃんとから来たんじゃ
あーなまあえっあオナニー飛んではあっ
おまっ
まだ起きたんだ
資生堂から行けますあ静岡
されたところからキュッって yamahon わー
まあ初産どっかできたは5ポンドしまーのもんやなあああ
声で